i want to get into the big drama of the
premiere
you versus jackie is quite the thing i
have to ask why
bring up this rumor you heard at all
knowing how you felt about similar
rumors being brought up in the past
listen i was fine with the rumors being
brought up like i stood up for myself
that happens you know what i mean like
someone it's like it's like your
girlfriend's telling you what's going on
or someone's telling you like and if
it's not going on then
you stand up for yourself so you know i
just wanted her to know
i didn't ruin the birthday party so i
just wanted her to know
that this rumor was out there and i
wanted her to stand up for herself
and defend herself so the rumor would
stop because
listen the rumor was out there and if it
wasn't
it's not like i made it up it was out
there i'm not saying it's true i'm not
saying it's not you like i didn't say
that
i just wanted her to know from a girl's
girl that it was out there
and for her to do something about it you
know i go around the party though and
kind of
ask people if they've heard it instead
of just going to her right away
privately i wasn't going to go to her
she was throwing a party
like it was her could do it you could do
it not at the party
have you ever heard that emily does
stuff at the gym what kind of stuff
it's like when he goes to the gym he's
screwing around
no no no teresa i was drinking a lot of
tequila
and then i don't know just and then i
was looking at him and i
this is how i work like just something
clicks in my brain
you know that's i mean i don't know if
that happens to you like that happens to
me like
i'm very spontaneous like i don't know
it's like something just clicked in my
brain
and i was telling my girlfriends like i
was telling
it's not like i told strangers and i
told my sister-in-law
i think i told margaret margaret and i
are close so that's right
you did it was everyone you have a
relationship with who you're close to
so you don't regret bringing this up at
all not really because like i'm a girls
girl
and that's why i would want to know i
really would want to know it was brought
up in the past
you know and i defended myself the sit
down between you and jackie
goes off the rails very quickly right
were you surprised that it it went south
so
fast i guess so because you know like
she tries to act like she's this
person that you know you could speak to
and she said she's a lawyer
and all this but you definitely have to
watch to see how it plays out yeah
i did not spread a rumor i heard
a rumor okay well you know what i heard
that gia snorts coke in the bathroom at
parties
okay i heard it i don't know where i
heard it i mean i heard from somebody
i mean but it's the same thing i think
she was trying to make a point and chose
the worst
analogy she possibly could a lawyer was
you know how she called herself a lawyer
being so smart
that was the worst analogy possible
and being a mom of four
very bad moves is that what anybody
anybody that would say something like
that about someone else's child
is like very disgraceful yeah as a
lawyer
not smart just saying i'm not smart at
all
i think it's safe to say hearing gia's
name just
set you off that's what did it for you
no one wants to hear their child's name
and you know especially in a negative
way the way she said it i have to say i
don't think the c word has been used
the number of times you use it in that
one moment
ever on reality tv before that's not a
word that i know i
never use that word that's not a word
that is in my vocabulary
it's just i was really upset she's
disgusting
no bring up
we know jackie decided to take a step
away from the group
after this moment were you surprised
that she
uh came back around um no no
where do things go after episode one
what can you tell me about this
journey i guess we'll see you in jackie
on is friendship
possible for the two of you um you're
gonna have to watch the show
and see how it plays out okay did you
prefer when she
was not around yeah obviously hello
after what she said i think the the
audience is gonna be
maybe not split but i do think people
will see this one of two ways either
teresa came and did her job or what
what was teresa thinking i think that's
going to be the conversation after the
first episode
like i said i was beaten and i'm a
girl's girl that was it
like that's how i feel you were being
true to yourself and what you
thought was necessary to do and it
wasn't just for tv
it's something you would do i don't know
group of girlfriends
you know i mean you guys have been with
me how long i
right what you see is what you get i am
very true i think it's
transparent as it comes as they come you
know as they come like so yeah i
am i am being sure to myself you know
there's a lot more you know
that you need to tune in and watch the
season it's not just about me and jackie
there's so much more
in watching the super tease it's very
apparent that you and jackie is going to
start off the season and then i think
it's going to be bom
bom bom bom bom every couple episodes
there's a lot even with the other girls
it's like it's you know
yeah everyone's personal story seems to
have something
to offer too it's like there's group
dynamics personal i
the first episode truly when i watched
it that
kind of flash forward of you and jackie
i thought was setting up
season long drama then to ca three days
earlier i went
oh no what are we in for this is a
season
yeah it's really it's an amazing season
i can't wait for everyone to watch
if you had to to describe it with one
word what's your word for season 11
i would say explosive
[Music]